good afternoon we are live now
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to
this webinar presented by the fiber home
council of europe
my name is tom bambery and i am
chairman of the deployment and
operations committee
at the fiber to home council i will be
the moderator for this event
for this event i will be joined by my
colleague raf mearsman
raf ceo of comsoff and is a board member
of the floyd home council also
the topic of the the webinar
is ftth and 5g
the success story of convergence
continued
and just very briefly to introduce the
topic
the deployment and operations committee
has been carrying out
work on convergence and
convergence particularly of 5g and ftdh
for a couple of years we have presented
seminars
at the ftth conference in
2019 and in 2020 on this topic
in 2019 the first study was presented
and it focused on the comparing the cost
of fiber to the home and fiber to the 5g
and looked at the cost savings that
could be
achieved through convergence of those
two
networks 2020 we took the study a little
bit further
and looked at the impact of adding in
spare capacity
at the start when you're building an
ftth network and how that could
create savings uh for a 5g build in the
future that was
unknown at the time when the ftth
network was built
so this webinar will present um a lot of
that work
and uh i'll provide some updates on the
conclusions uh
from from that as well okay um if you
move on the slides please wrap one
so we also have as part of the
um the webinar the opportunity to
use an online polling system if
you can copy the uh the
scan code there on your screen this will
bring you to
a web page or an app that will allow you
to answer some questions
so we'll have a couple of questions
throughout the
webinar and this is the first one so
anybody who's
scanned the the q code now you can start
answering the questions
and really the question we're asking is
in relation to 5g
looking at the x and y axis from your
perspective
how are where are you in relation to 5g
in terms of technology technical details
and in the business case so on the
x-axis
um the further right you are the more
more comfortable you are to technology
and on the y-axis the for the higher up
you are the more comfortable you are
with the business case
so please continue to answer that and we
will look at how the
the poll looks later in the presentation
okay i think we can see some some people
are already starting to answer that so
um so a little bit more of an
introduction um
in terms of the agenda here i'm just
going to do a quick introduction on the
topic of convergence and on 5g just a
little background
um but that'll be very quick and then
i'll hand over to raph
in a couple of minutes so um that that
would be the
the uh i guess agenda for the day or
terms of the the sequence of speakers
if we talk about convergence uh moving
quickly onto this slide
basically a converged network is a
network that
can carry out a number of functions or
can support a number of
solutions or applications a lot of the
studies we're talking about here
is a converged access network that can
support ftth
and 5g and we'll talk more in a minute
about the reasons why that's a why
that's required
you know effectively what's happening in
the world
right now is you know not just ftth and
5g but other
phenomena like internet of things like
uh
smart cities and like ever growing
enterprise applications
are leading to an ever increasing demand
for for optical fiber within the
networks
to deal with the sheer volume of traffic
so what you
ultimately could conceivably end up with
is a converged network that supports not
just
ft th and 5g but a converged network for
everything fiber to the everything
effectively
and what we are focusing on in this
study is just
the the combination of the
i guess you call it the retail services
5g and
ftth so moving on again please
uh thinking about 5g you know
i think you know unless you've been uh
asleep or on the moon or something for
the last
10 years everybody knows that the world
of mobile communications is moving
towards 5g
you know from 3g 20 years ago and 4g
probably came 10 years ago
and now 5g is the way of the future and
what does 5g deliver
that you know wasn't available in
previous generations
i think if you look at this this figure
here you're really looking at the three
corners of the triangle
on top you know enhanced mobile
broadband so gigabits in a second
massive machine type communication
supporting things like smart city
applications
and then very very high reliability and
very low latency communications so
uh that would then support um new
applications such as self-driving
vehicles etc and other mission critical
applications
and what this does you know when you
think about it is this enables the
future of tech
you know this creates the the vehicle
and the platform
on which future tech innovations that we
probably haven't even thought up of yet
become enabled and available to us as
consumers
so that's where 5g it just drives the
use for more technology
moving on again the other thing that's
going to happen is
as this gets deployed it
just creates huge growth in the
number and variety of devices that are
connected to a network
and generating data um the uh the graph
on the
on the top left of the screen shows a
projection of the number of
connected devices worldwide in billions
and goes from
roughly 35 billion here in 2021
and suggests we're getting to 75 billion
by 2025
that's roughly 10 devices for every
human being on the planet
which is uh pretty phenomenal it's
already set five devices for every human
being on the planet
and heading to twice that um as well as
the sheer number of devices increasing
the variety of devices increasing so
things that are not
connected today or have not been
connected up to recently
become connected devices and you can
even see the picture of the
the agriculture and machinery there
becoming a connected device
traffic lights refrigerators watches
manufacturing equipment etc and then the
end points at which
networks terminate these are growing and
ever increasing as well
smart cities creating terminations at
traffic lights
mobile communications small cells
manufacturing sites as well as
residential sites and data centers
what this does is it creates a demand
for more and more content more and more
data
and in order to deal with that in a
wireless network we have to look at
where we go with spectrum because
spectrum is the scarce commodity that is
required in order to move
information through through a wireless
network
legacy mobile networks um have used the
existing mobile spectrum shown here
below six gigahertz
5g uses that spectrum but will also use
very high capacity spectrum in the
millimeter waveband
the the key thing about this is that it
enables very high capacity and very high
data rates
however it is not suitable for
very uh very long uh microwave or
wireless links the the range is quite
small
struggles to penetrate through buildings
and fabrics etc
so fiber as the the backhaul medium is
something that
is is highly desirable when you start to
use this this
uh this spectrum
so these are some of the factors around
5g
and 5g as it converges with an ftth
network
the use of a very high frequency
spectrum the requirement
to converge and use deep fiber
etc and the ever increasing number of
locations
and devices that will be connected so
convergence in order to support that
certainly makes sense from a technical
perspective
but what about the business case and
that's really what we're here about
today
uh and that's what the uh the purpose of
the studies that the fiber home council
has worked on
is to really look at the business case
around this and whether it works from a
financial perspective
and with that i will hand over to raf
sorry one last thing
we will take questions at the end there
is a facility
on the on the webinar for people to
submit questions online
and would be happy to uh to take
questions later on over to you ralph
yes thank you tom uh for the intro and
uh yes
it's my great pleasure to give you some
more insights on this
study results um i would also like to
make clear this is a study done under
the dna committee umbrella so i have the
pleasure of
being a bit of a project manager on this
and therefore
also sharing the results but it is a
team effort
and we work together with a lot of
companies that are part of the dno
committee
to come up with these uh studies now
if you look at the
let's say the key questions within the
study that we were looking to find an
answer for
and as tom mentioned that's like started
more than two years ago
um first of all when we look at 5g one
thing that we found
crucial was to get a real verification
of the cell densification factor
how many cells do we really need that
that's a very key
input to um to our convergent story
we also really wanted to check and
focus on um is there a difference for
this business case for this convergence
story
in a rural versus an urban area um
then we also wanted to get a feeling
about how much fiber you really need to
to be 5g ready and ultimately how much
cost
can we save if we plan a network of
fiber network in a smart way
through convergence so hopefully
throughout the presentation we can share
answers to a lot of
questions for a number of
yeah specific cases because ultimately
what we do
is try to come up with answers for
some cases that means it's not
necessarily an answer that
is viable for any case but at least
they're realistic
and aligned with the assumptions the
good thing is today we have a little bit
more time
than typically in a conference or so so
we will be able also to dive into some
more details
of the assumptions and the model behind
this study result
now tom already touched upon it 5g
the spectrum usage of 5g is is
very different from 4g at the same time
i'm getting often some questions on yes
but
the people are deploying 5g today but
it's it's
for example in europe mainly in these
sub
six gigahertz bands um that's true and
then we'll come back to that in the
assumptions
um but um let's say it's my firm believe
that if we really want to
explore all the possibilities of a 5g
technology
at some stage we will also start looking
at those higher frequencies because
there's simply not enough space
in the spectrum to realize all the
applications
in our study we made some assumptions on
the spectrum we looked at a 3.5
gigahertz
and we also looked at introducing 5g on
26 gigahertz
to quite um yeah popular uh
frequencies um but um it's important to
notice
if we talk today about deploying a fiber
network
and this fiber network would be intended
to to be used for the long term
um well in five or ten years from now we
may be looking at six g seven g
nobody knows what it exactly will look
like but if there's one thing for sure
that is that it will also use a broad
spectrum
and will need a lot of that frequencies
to deliver more uh services
so um why is that frequency so
so and so important why do we emphasize
on that
well that's just laws of physics
looking at the radiation and
transmitting
wireless signals at a certain
frequencies there is an
important impact from a frequency on the
coverage
on the reach that you have this is
nicely illustrated here
in this propagation model by cyrodill
where you see at a five gigahertz
frequency
from a certain antenna how far the
signal can reach what you also clearly
see on the picture is that
especially when it's well positioned
through a tunnel
you can reach quite a far distance but
obviously also
buildings at five gigahertz start to be
a real
obstacle for for a good signal
penetration
but if you then look for a similar
place but at a higher frequency the
reach is
much smaller because yeah the signal
attenuates much quicker
and that that is the reason why cell
densification
is uh is coupled to the whole 5g
idea and why you can see if you want to
deliver a service across a certain area
that you will need to increase the
number of antennas
and then just to illustrate conceptually
why
this is such an interesting evolution
in terms of convergence look at this
concept with a couple of houses on a
couple of streets
and if you deploy an
fiber network to these homes and
separately you would deploy fiber to the
5g antennas
uh of course you can see on the picture
there's a lot of double trenching
there's a lot of separate cables being
installed so you
you would end up with two quite costly
networks and that
you would have to bear that cost
separately
whereas if you would deploy these
infrastructure
in a smart way one one time
or at least on on some level of
trenching for example big ones
it's clear that you can optimize the
whole infrastructure the whole routing
the whole
cable and duct amounts
um to serve these endpoints in an
optimized network
and reducing the overall cost so
avoiding double trenches were possible
and even avoiding double ducts for
example
so now let's dive into
some more details of the model and the
assumptions behind
some of our key results that we
calculated
in the study
this is a bit of an overview of this
end-to-end model
um we applied actually the combination
of a wireless
5g propagation model and a wire line
calculation model on gis data both
models work on detailed gis data because
we really wanted to
not just keep it theoretically and use
some average numbers
but really take a real area take the
real data
and really show what it actually
looks like for those areas that means we
start off
with actually a 3d view on an
on a selected area where we also have
candidate
5g poles we model and
select the number of technical
parameters on the 5g
and then through this model we can
select
a logical required number of 5g
sites for the future um and
with those sites combined with the the
other demand points in the area which in
our case are the homes
um we can do a calculation of a
standalone fiber to the home
standalone fiber to 5g and then a
converged
single network to come up with those
ratios and see what actually can be
saved
so we'll dive into more details of those
assumptions uh
in a second first of all on the areas i
i told
in the beginning we wanted also to see
what is the situation in urban
versus rural so we ended up with three
different areas on which we applied our
calculations
ranging from a very urban city center
with a lot of
multi-dwelling units high-rise buildings
a lot of visitors and public places
all the way to a rural area where we
have isolated villages
and very scarce population
so we have results on these three areas
also the middle one
which is a relatively dense but more
single dwelling
type residential area
as i said and this is yeah very crucial
on each of these areas
we gathered and and were able to uh
achieve this real life 3d lidar data
which means we have
a 3d virtual
environment in which we can actually
completely simulate the reality
for the 5g propagation and for the fiber
layout
[Music]
as candidate polls we also loaded
all the existing lamp posts in the area
as a discrete set of candidates to
install small cells
where then the softwares can actually
select
the best subset to reach a certain
coverage
here you see for example for the dense
area how this data looks like
you see really uh yeah the the height of
the buildings
you see obstacles which are important
especially on higher frequencies
this is crucial to know how your signal
will propagate
throughout the area
now when we then looked at what is a
realistic scenario of deploying 5g
what could be the frequencies and the
coverage that an operator could
want to achieve on this 5g network we
came up with these
different cell density scenarios per
area
and just to give a little bit more
background
um you see on the high dense area for
example
we set already one
densification scenario that is realistic
is to just deploy 5g at 3.5 gigahertz
um and try to come to 100
coverage um a lot of the 4g networks are
deployed at
2.6 gigahertz so we we do operate here
at a slightly higher
um frequency um so there will already be
a need for additional
cells to get 100 coverage
what we also see in the high dens area
with train stations
shopping malls is that there is an
in there is a need typically early on
for indoor hotspots
because higher frequencies don't
penetrate the buildings as
good um but then on the other extreme
side of a high dense area
what we anticipate there is that we add
an
other layer of in this case 95
coverage at a 26 gigahertz so you kind
of get
um an extremely well covered
high frequency high frequency high
bandwidth
uh area um that's a quite extreme
scenario that this is not gonna happen
anywhere i think in the next four or
five years
in my personal opinion or let's say at
least not in
two three years i think in europe um
but it's more or less a natural
evolution as well
uh 5g rollouts will more most likely
happen in
phases where an increased coverage at
higher frequencies can be introduced
gradually
and that's more or less what we have in
these different scenarios here as well
also important to mention is on the
rural area we looked at
already an improved situation versus
today to deploy 5g
on 3.5 gigahertz for reaching a 70
coverage in the populated villages
um which would actually uh also give a
30
indoor coverage and so it should be
clear this is not
really an alternative for a pure
fixed wired connection because also the
indoor coverage
is not as easy there's no way we look at
26 gigahertz at this time as
a business case for rural so our high
dense
scenario in rural was based on
increasing that coverage especially also
indoor at 3.5 gigahertz to a 92
so you see the assumptions are quite
different in rural
and in urban driven by the commercials
of it as well of course there's a lot of
different scenarios you can think of
but at least what we see with these
assumptions is that this could be a
gradual part a face roll out in
different types of areas
that could happen and that would
actually over time always increase
the number of cell sites to cover these
these areas
as i mentioned on the 5g side um we also
tried to put in the technical
parameters and assumptions to see what
actually would be
the type of service the type of
bandwidth that we could be offering with
with that certain technology so you see
here for example
a number of very detailed technical
specs on a
3.5 gigahertz 5g rollout it's not
said that definitely not
every operator will will use these
settings
but they are realistic they are
checked with with experts that this
could be a way
to deploy the 5g network and what's
important well first of all in in the
bandwidth
that we have in the 3.5 gigahertz
spectrum
the there are some more limitations so
we assumed here
an 80 or 40 megahertz bandwidth that is
available so that typically we would
have
one in an auction um and
also important is the signal
well signal to interference plus noise
ratio is the technical term
but that's basically um how much
attenuation you
uh you allow given the interference and
the noise
that is added on top of the signals and
that is
an important parameter to see how far
ultimately we can reach
with a certain quality and you see here
as well
with these settings we assume that
when you are in coverage of this cell
that we can offer a 15 to 30 megabits
per second
bandwidth uh of course as a shared
medium
so you see this is a nice bandwidth but
not
a revolution in terms of the bandwidth
experience
on on the device
if you then look for example with our
20s introducing 26 gigahertz 5g
you see that there we assume there's a
bit more bandwidth available
because there's still just some more
space there
but at the same time there is also more
troubles to be expected on the um
on the attenuation but you do see as
well um
that our simulations are able to go
up to 191 megabits per second delivered
from the small cell as a capacity across
the sector so
now we start talking about real real big
speeds in a mobile technology of course
all of these parameters are configured
in the propagation model together with
the input data that is the 3d lidar data
and then thanks to our partner cyrodill
with their model
we were able to identify the best
locations
for cell sites at these frequencies to
reach the
required coverage so
um let's do another quick question
so you uh hopefully you still have the
the page open or otherwise you can
reopen it at pov.com
console for scan the qr code
and then you should automatically see
this question pop-up
on how many sell sites that you think
there will be
in your country let's say in five years
from now
as opposed to today is it going to be
double
four times 10 times 30 times
let's see answers are coming in so we
should see them
coming in live as well
some mixed results
so a lot of different opinions
okay
so these are the yeah these are the
final
um results so we see that uh
the majority things between four and ten
in five years from now
i think that's uh a pretty good
guess or you know it
but it's also interesting to see it
could even go higher
this will definitely depend on the area
and
the situation in the country
but it seems also everybody is uh the
large majority
is convinced of the cell densification
that will happen in the coming years
now let's look at um our example and
what's identification translates into
which factor we
ultimately come up with so here you see
this dense area to illustrate and you
see the red triangles being the macro
cells so this is where currently 4g
is being being deployed um
at first the first stage which would be
logical
is to deploy the 5g technology on these
macro cells
at 3.5 gigahertz um it's i think
a step that a lot of operators will be
taking and when
there's announcements of we're rolling
out 5g i think today
it's a lot about this first step
but as we mentioned well at 3.5
gigahertz if you do the analysis from
the existing macro cells
you will find that there are islands
with um
with uh yeah not a good enough coverage
so to reach a 100 coverage at 3.5
gigahertz
um we can see that there is in meat
already for introducing some small cells
uh in between and in the black
spots or the the white spots however you
want to call them
from the macro sites in our calculation
here we
introduce 11 additional small cells
in this area to reach 100
coverage and as i mentioned we also saw
in this
region that there are 13 interesting
indoor hot spots like a train station
like a museum like a shopping mall
because there are a lot of visitors
there's a lot of users
and there is some issue with the indoor
coverage
in those areas so that's
you see we are going here from 6 to 30
already
in order to reach this this type of
coverage
if we then say okay let's put another
layer on top of 26 gigahertz coverage
for 50
of the area it means if you have a
mobile device and you would
actually be in the area you would have a
one on two
percent uh one on two uh chance
that you have the 26 gigahertz high
bandwidth
if you are not in reach your device
would fall back to a lower
speed of course um now to reach 50
coverage
we calculated that we needed a minimum
of 29
additional um small cells the ones here
in blue
because we're also reusing the small
cells that we already had for 3.5
gigahertz
to deploy the 26 gigahertz so in total
we go now to
60 cells or a factor 10.
and then ultimately well ultimately we
say
let's try to reach 95 percent uh well
you already see
for 95 coverage we need to introduce a
lot of
small cells um actually
it's a total of 87
additional small cells on top of the
earlier ones
reaching about a factor 20. so
if you of course are if you're convinced
95 coverage at 26 gigahertz is not
realistic or feasible anytime soon then
of course this factor 20 is
overestimated
but again when we talk about preparing
our networks and infrastructure for the
future
of the mobile networks we also need to
consider the lifetime of the fiber
infrastructure that is
quite long so we do need to anticipate
this
unknown high density future
now through all these calculations we
found ideal
locations for the 5g mobile sites
and so that's uh and that's the points
that we then want to fiberize
um so we feed these points into the map
and we also add the homes because
we also want to bring fiber to the home
to the whole area
we will specify the architecture of a
fiber network
which means this can be a hybrid
point-to-point network
and we'll come into some more details
later on
um so we feed all of that input into the
calculation model
and then we calculate on the map an
accurate realistic fttx network design
within uh
automatically generated bit of material
that provides us with
the cost details to build this network
so as such for any densification
scenario for any
uh area density um and for any of the
technical
assumptions we can calculate all the
necessary
costs um to see what what comes out
now on the ftdx parameters that are
configured
some more details here so um there's a
lot of variations depending on the
country the
operator the area how networks are being
deployed
so we just took some standards uh
of course you can rerun the model with a
lot of variations
but let's say we've taken some
assumptions here
within the dno committee that were
supported
in several projects across europe that
means for private to the home
we are actually calculating a model with
a one on 32 splitter
in the distribution points or a gpal
network
we foresee two fibers per home we have
some cabinets
where we have flexibility up to 96 homes
on a cabinet
the network initially is considered to
be deployed completely underground
using microducts and air blown fiber and
we deploy some
mid-span access feeder cables of 96 or
48 fibers
for the fiber to 5g we calculated with
some
variations um different fiber counts
whether
we would foresee 12 or 4 fibers per
cell site but we also
played around with do we make those
fibers point to point
or do we make them point to multi-point
ultimately most of our results are based
on this third
scenario where we would actually bring
12 active and 12
spare fibers to every cell side this
means it's also
um foreseen typically for multiple
operators to
put their wireless technology on the
side
um but we do introduce some level of
fiber aggregation
through a splitter a higher up in the
network in order to reduce that fiber
count
throughout the network
on the costs also very important
there is a difference between the urban
and rural areas
and the numbers we've taken for the
major results
are like 80 euro up to or down to
35 euro per meter for trenching
and these numbers are actually also
aligned with the former
ftth cost model for europe which we
did eight eight years ago or something
so they were also gathered by
several members of the dno committee
the costs are obviously uh important
there are also geographical differences
so in some countries
for sure trenching costs will be much
cheaper
than this in some countries for an urban
area it could be more expensive
if you would use micro trenching the
cost would be again completely different
again these are things that we could
change in the model
but now we work with let's say this as a
as a starting point
and then ultimately also important to
mention that
the costs we are reporting focus on that
outside plans passive network
so we don't include things like ont
olt costs or fiber
sorry 5g active equipment or for example
spectrum costs
and all of those costs are not envisaged
we focus on
how much of that shared fiber
infrastructure outside
can actually be saved in
in the convergence
here you see a map um to show you uh
yeah the real results that were
generated that it's not
an excel model but it's really a
detailed model
and if you think about those all those
streets and houses and you look at
the locations of the of the 5g antennas
i think it's fairly easy to see
the opportunity that lies ahead
especially if you look at this high
density you're virtually in every street
or
every one another street
you are deploying fiber um for the five
gk's already
but you're also coming into that street
for the fiber to the home network
so zooming in you clearly see that
building this once will drastically
reduce the overall cost
because you can avoid a lot of double
trenching
okay let's uh go through some of the
main results
of this study and model based on the
assumptions
that i just uh presented we already saw
these densification factors that we
assumed factor 5 to 20 in urban
and and again it's it's important to see
that these are typically
probably rather roll out phases and
stages
rather than just a future end result
or end scenario
on rural we we have for example here
also what you could see as a faith
rollout but we see there that we go from
two macro sites
uh today to a situation where we had
um 16 sites to reach a decent 3.5
gigahertz coverage also indoor
and so you see that the factor here is a
bit smaller
than in the urban area with these
assumptions
here you see that illustrated as well
for a village
where it's also well crucial to see the
difference in the indoor coverage
this is where the extra cells are
are needed
um so that gives us um
ultimately also the cost results that we
calculated the cost for a standalone
fiber to the home
standalone fiber to 5g and then a
converged network
which the x percent the blue arrow
would be the the percentage that we can
uh save now if we relate
the amount here that we can decrease
versus the standalone of fiber to 5g
that is what we were looking for how
much of the 5g
standalone fiber network can we
eliminate
by building it in a converged way now
as a last small polling question there
again on the same page you can
provide your answer to this question
what percentage of cost
of the 5g standalone do you think can be
saved
typically in our calculations here with
these assumptions
true convergence is it 10 20
40 60 or 80 percent
if all goes well we see the answers
coming in so we see there is a
slight preference or idea about the 20
um 20 to 40 percent savings
so 20 to 40 of the fiber to 5g cost that
can be saved
through the conversions well let's have
a look at the real results that came out
of our calculations
so this is the example high dense area
so very
density center with the ultimate high
dense
scenario and you see we ended up with
a network of 8.5 million euro
for the fiber to the home standalone
1.85
or 5 to 5g and about 9 million
for the converged network that means in
this case
we could actually eliminate 75
74 of the standalone 5g fiber network
by building it in one case so even
higher
than what is expected as we see in the
polling
and the actual additional cost is only
half a million on top of the 8.5 million
represents only five six five to six
percent
of the original investment for a
standalone fiber to the whole network
now as we mentioned we applied this
calculations to
all our scenarios so also to low dense
areas and
low cell density so you see the
74 and 5.6 that i just showed you on the
high dense area high cell density
now interesting is that if you go to low
cell density
um yeah less cells means a smaller fiber
network means it's
it's even easier to bring i do let's say
yeah uh build it into the fiber to the
home
so it's it's almost for free
that you can accommodate that
um but um i think more importantly
it's also interesting to see that on the
rural areas
we also have still 65
savings which is i think more than we
anticipated before
so it's not that different uh the
the savings that could be achieved
through this conversion so the
convergence definitely
is not just a thing in the urban areas
it also has the benefits in the
more rural areas one other
uh calculation that we did was to switch
over from an underground to an
aerial network so introducing poles and
deploying aerial
cables obviously will will bring a whole
other uh
flexibility to the network and that does
translate into quite a different number
but you see for this scenario
underground where we had 83 percent
saving through convergence in an aerial
case
the network initially is cheaper but
the extension and the level of
convergence opportunity
is a lot smaller um of course because
it's
less trenching less ducting and more
cable costs which are less easier
uh less easy to share
so again assumptions are crucial if you
have a hybrid underground aerial model
it may end up somewhere in between but
of course
the best thing to know is always to
calculate it with the real numbers
now just on those results a lot of
questions that came was also
okay that's fine if you know what the
future of the 5g
looks like if you know where the
antennas are gonna
be installed but we don't know it
typically today so how can we be 5g
ready without knowing where 5g will
really be well that means you need to
foresee
spare capacity in a fiber rollout today
for an unknown future and the question
is how much spare capacity
would be enough um given that
uncertainty
so we built further on these models and
on these data
we took the high dense area again same
area
we introduced 12 24 and 48 percent spare
in three scenarios
and then we said okay let's then assume
we built that network with that spare
that is reserved for 5g
and let's assume in five years from now
we
we know at that time what the 5g looks
like
we consider it to be the high cell
density scenario
with 95 coverage on 26 gigahertz
and let's see how much of that future
network fits into our
spare capacity so it's a bit
similar but uh with a level of
uncertainty at the time we built the
fiber network
again we're using microducts in the
assumptions we're
building it based on a certain
number of ducts or subducts that we
actually reserve for 5g
averaging out to these 12 24 and 48
and then illustrating it here you see
that
we would actually deploy these micro
duct bundles
for fiber to the home but reserving
always a minimum
spare ducts the blue ones there that
should not be used for anything else in
the future 5g network
and then we see depending on how much
power there is
that the 5g might fit into it for some
parts
and then we avoid double trenching but
for some parts the capacity is
full and there may still be
additional trenching because we didn't
anticipate enough
capacity looking at the costs
you can see here a standalone at 8.5
million
euro as before the standalone 5g at 8
1.8 million but we also discount that
over five years so the net present value
with eight percent would be 1.25 so we
have a total net present value of
building two separate
non-converged networks and then if we
introduce twelve percent spare
we see a very slightly increase of the
cost
not a lot because we already have ducts
that we can
reserve for this and we see a decrease
of the 5g
so reusing that spare capacity is good
but still overall the decrease is not
significant
going to 24 we see the increase a bit
further
but especially there we see a big
decrease of the 5g
cost um going to 48 that increase
a bit higher but the decrease is not
spectacular anymore
and to reference at the previous result
uh of building it today knowing what 5g
would look like
i would actually end up with an almost 9
million
euro bringing that together um the
conclusion here in this case stacking
those different values you clearly see
that well 12 in these cases with these
assumptions was
clearly not enough we didn't get the
full value of the convergence out of
this network
um but in these assumptions with the 24
we were able to capture the majority
of that value of convergence
or put a bit differently here you see
the um
the the how this
cost for 5 key can be reduced
by reusing the different levels of spare
capacity
now i do have to warn a bit with with
this result
that um what we clearly do not want to
state is that
every case 24 will be the ideal or
best spare capacity for 5g
um again it depends on the assumptions
the case the
the density and the parameters that you
would put in
um but nevertheless again a very
realistic result
based on realistic inputs from start to
finish
um and interesting to see that you do
need to foresee the right level of spare
capacity
um because 5g is quite heavy on fiber
demand in the future
um so um yeah 12 is already significant
but clearly not enough
under these assumptions
okay so our key findings of the whole
study
was that there was a huge cost saving
for building the fiber to the home and
the 5g network together
this was the first result between 65 and
96
of the 5g fiber cost could be
eliminated by building it together
at least for the underground scenario um
then um we also looked at if you would
build it today
fiber to the home with only limited
spare capacity 12
or lower well you would incur additional
costs for the future 5g network
over a reasonable lifetime of the fiber
it's not like the fiber network is going
to be
renewed in that time frame so we ended
up with two to three and a half times as
expensive to roll out fiber for 5g
this is also one of the reasons why we
definitely believe that areas where
there is
spare capacity in fiber rollouts today
will be
the areas where 5g networks could be
leading in the future
because of course this will impact the
business case enormously
if that fiber spare capacity is
available or not
um and then lastly as a let's say a
tip uh good practice uh is
okay often you don't know yet what that
future 5g
really densified scenario will look like
but there is a way to anticipate on it
and that's by building sufficient spare
capacity
into the networks of today
so um that's uh
let's say a walk through our complete 5g
convergence
model and study i would definitely like
to thank
our contributing members and people from
the working group
on this study uh who contributed a lot
with the
discussions on assumptions model and
calculations and results
and i'm happy to hand over to tom to
treat any questions that we may have
thank you ralph and uh we'll let you
catch your breath there for a second
because i
think that was a whistle-stop tour of a
a couple of very large studies and i
think
some of these uh these slides are
available already
on the fth council website from previous
seminars and the fta th conferences
and there's also a white paper that
we've published on on this topic also
that can be downloaded
from the ftth council website so if
anybody has
interest in exploring the topic further
i would uh certainly encourage them to
go and
look at those um initially
um maybe good to mention tom just
quickly is that
um it's indeed um this presentation
combines a lot of slides from
previous workshops and study uh
presentations so i do think indeed the
good thing is this is a bit of a total
overview of everything we did
over the past three years so definitely
uh
the best version if you're interested a
lot of the other presentations
on the website will typically only
highlight a part of this so this is a
i think a nice uh overall um
overview of everything yep although i
think there's
very few people who could uh go through
it all as quickly as you have in the
last
35 minutes and take it all in um
i have a just a couple of questions ref
um
does uh i guess one on the um
the the first study regarding the the
savings
um of building a converged network
versus building
um standalone networks if you look at
um say the uh
either the high cell density or the
medium cell density scenario
and you consider going from a densely
populated area to a suburban area to a
medium area or to a low populated area
you can see that the you know the the
savings seem to
increase and then they decrease again
is there any you know reason why
why why that occurs is or is it maybe
within the just the
the boundaries of error of the
simulations
um yes i think so um
it's indeed it's a very good observation
um
i don't have a complete logical
explanation for it
except that indeed uh what we really do
is take
yeah three areas three um different
cases and we calculated and these are
the numbers
um and and results in this kind of
simulations
is not always completely covered by the
assumptions you're looking at there's
indeed sometimes
other assumptions underneath that could
influence for example one
one influencing factor could be the
difference
in the unit cost of trenching
between a suburban and an urban area
but we we have not been able to really
pinpoint or
or find it out um so i think the
the the conclusion of this is that
every case is different and it's it's
what we want to avoid a bit is that
these numbers would be used also
as um the truth and the
the barriers and the and the extrapolate
on this where you are
no actually every area can have
different aspects
we illustrate in material areas but
it's not yeah 100 guaranteed that the
same number will apply to every medium
dense area for example
that's fair okay um and then
i'm relating to the uh the second study
which i think
you know probably is it uh
of great interest of people who are
considering right now building ftth
networks and trying to understand
what their spare capacity policy should
be because that
truly has to be one of the big questions
is what's going to be the need in the
future how many fibers do i
really need how many dots do i really
need etc and this
this has put some interesting numbers on
the table there
um just one thought that struck uh one
question we received
regarding this was the sparing policy
here seems to be around
spare duct um and if you had
taken an approach of instead of maybe
using
96 fiber cables to go with a 288 fiber
cable or a 432 fiber cable
would that deliver
similar savings or would it greatly
increase the day one cost of the ftth
network
so much that it it doesn't make make
sense so
um that's a you know the comparison
between
duct sparing versus fibrous bearing as
your day once bearing policy
yeah yeah yeah it's a very good question
you could actually
uh perfectly also do it on a
on a fiber level to fossil spare fibers
for future 5g
in fact well i briefly touched upon that
aerial case
where on ariel yeah you would probably
have to do it that way to foresee
immediately the fibers if you really
want to
benefit from the convergence but the
reason why we
did take the duct level is that you do
have a lot of flexibility indeed
building the duct network on day one is
not the most expensive
and indeed in the end five years later
in this
scenario when we then uh know where 5g
comes
obviously we only blow the necessary
fiber capacity
through the empty ducts where they're
needed
which also indeed means we're not
putting a lot of cables in the ground
where they're not needed
and so it is indeed a bit of a balance
between the pre-investment
and then keeping a flexibility to
actually deploy additional capacity
where
ultimately you need it in five years
from now that you may not
know today so it's indeed a scenario
well we could calculate it on a fiber
level as well but it would indeed
incur the additional cost and then yeah
i'm not sure
overall if that will be a more cost
efficient way
um for the underground scenario against
okay thank you um we have a
question coming on on the webinar as
well uh to what extent do you consider
5g millimeter wave as a compliment or a
substitute to ftth
i guess that's as much a question for
the council as it is
for the people presenting this webinar i
would say that the uh
the council's uh position on that would
be that the the
technologies are complementary um and
that there will always be a need for
for you know the the fixed network
termination point
to uh to deliver stuff that we don't
even even know about yet so it's uh it's
definitely a complimentary technology
and my
my from my perspective and be happy for
you to maybe chip in there as well if
you have anything
anything else to say on that yeah i i
obviously fully agree
in the sense also that if you looked at
some of the numbers i
shared if you want to really deliver a
high
bandwidth to to all residential users
you have two problems i think with uh
with 5g
only for that and assuming you wouldn't
need the fiber to home
the two things is one you would need to
go into the high frequencies because
we're talking about
bandwidth needs that are uh very high
especially for home users
more and more that bandwidth need is
high so you're talking about
moving very closely with your antenna so
fixed wireless access examples on 60
gigahertz
for example in us have been deployed but
then you
also have that issue of the higher the
frequency the more the line of sight
and the even like penetration in the
building
is is becoming a problem um i've even
heard
for example an anecdote of an um 60
gigahertz
what fixed wireless access uh solution
that was working very
good in the in the summer
now sorry in the in the winter having a
line of sight to
to a building antenna and then suddenly
in spring
flower leaves came on the tree and the
signal
degraded suddenly so
i don't think it's the the thing for
high bandwidth that would
replace the quality and stability let
alone
on sustainability where i think dno is
also doing some study work
on the fact that fiber can actually be
also
a low energy sustainability
this is true um okay um we received one
other question which came in by email
prior to the uh
the webinar regarding optimizing the uh
microducts and micro cables and bundles
of duct and i think we've addressed that
in the content
of the of the webinar if the individual
or the company that sent
in that question would like to clarify
further
on on the question please feel free to
to send in another email and we'll
we'll attempt to answer but i think
raphu you covered it pretty well in
terms of the sparing policy and the
ducts etc
so um i don't need to discuss that any
further um i
don't think there are any further
questions
um i don't see any on the webinar so um
with that i think we can draw the
session to a close thank you very much
raf
thank you very much to the council for
organizing the webinar and
indeed to everybody in the audience
thank you for your your time
and your attention yes thank you
have a good day thank you